cette petite est un miracle de la
médecine
tiana six ans a déjà un lourd vécu
jusqu'à l'âge de deux ans et demi
c'était une enfant au développement
normal j'ai dit mbaye thiam en a mangé
dans l'auto sont bégaud en a parlé on a
joué deux heures l'après midi on reçoit
un appel de lagarde a dit qu'elle avait
tombé sur cette photo prise le matin du
29 ou 2013
on y voit la petite rihanna souriante
l'oeil allumé quelques heures avant sa
première crise d'épilepsie ses parents
ne la verront plus sourire de cette
façon pendant des mois aux mondiaux
après de nombreux tests on découvre
qu'elle est atteinte d'une maladie très
rare une encéphalite auto immunes chaque
jour le nombre de crises d'épilepsie
augmentait pour atteindre jusqu'à 500
par jour
les spécialistes ont tout essayé mais
rien n'y faisait
c'est le jeune neurologue pédiatrique et
médecins de tiana bradley ostermann
centre hospitalier de l'université laval
qui a eu une idée étonnante guérir sa
petite patiente avec un régime
alimentaire cétogène on a construit des
traitements un peu plus qu'ils n'ont
jamais été utilisés pour cette maladie
auto immune mais qui qui peuvent être
très utiles pour dépasser épileptique ce
qu'elle peut pas manger ce qui concerne
les glucides comme du pain et du riz du
lait les produits led 6 mai ça dit
consiste surtout de en fait le gras one
donna le traitement de l'épilepsie par
une diète cétogène est déjà connue par
le corps médical
mais la petite diana n'est pas
épileptiques ces crises étaient le
symptôme de sa maladie auto immune
si on regarde la littérature on n'est
pas moi je suis pas au courant de notre
cas où est ce qu'on est tenté ça avec
sont tout autant de succès en moins de
quatre semaines son état a changé du
tout au tout elle a commencé à parler l
air à commencer demain
marché les mafias me regarde pas a dit
haye piste est la première fois que
seulement trois ans que j'ai pas entendu
un mot sorti de là et pour ajouter aux
bonnes nouvelles
un des effets secondaires de la diète
cétogène la maladie auto immune de tiana
est maintenant guéri
ici elle couture radio canada montréal